what's up with laura barton and that
fancy shield rolex why didn't we get
more pizza dog hawkeye was a hoot but it
left fans with some burning questions
oddly enough in a show that includes
several unrepentant criminals and
killers eleanor bishop might be the most
raging sociopath of them all kate's
impressively manipulative mother reacts
to her arrest for first-degree murder as
if it was a particularly mean-spirited
personal attack it seems she's hardly
overflowing with remorse for the slaying
of armand duquesne and who knows how
many other crimes she committed on
kingpin's behalf how could you do this i
handled our mod like you all these years
now that kate's partly responsible for
her mom presumably serving a lengthy
prison sentence she may no longer have
access to the bishop family cash however
if she gets a side gig waiting tables
how will this facilitate her inevitable
first meetings with the rest of the
young avengers that's where this is all
heading right valentina allegra de
fontaine is presumably putting together
a thunderbolts team composed of copycat
avengers which includes u.s agent and
yelena bilova as the new black widow and
they'll take on a young avengers team
led by kate right well that's just a
guess what we know for sure is hawkeye
ends with kate enjoying christmas with
the bartons will she chill at the farm
for a while head back to new york blast
into space for an adventure with the
guardians of the galaxy the
possibilities are limitless
yelena belova doesn't appear until the
closing minutes of episode four but
florence pugh nevertheless walks away
with this whole series oddly enough she
does not walk away with black widow the
2021 feature length in which she
premieres as natasha romanov's adopted
sister it could be that the lighter tone
and premise of hawkeye lends itself to a
funnier yelena than the more serious
black widow could get away with as
hawkeye comes to a close yelena's
mission to execute clint barton is a
total wash but she gets some degree of
emotional closure for the death of her
sister at the moment there doesn't seem
to be more stuff for elena to do except
possibly to seek out and mentally
liberate any remaining brainwashed black
widows and await instructions from
valentina allegra de fontaine pew and
haley steinfeld also demonstrate
impressive on-screen chemistry within
relatively short periods of time so
while it's well and good to root for a
hawkeye and black widow show starring
the two somewhere down the line let's
remember that they can be bitter enemies
and still banter
starting with avengers age of ultron
from all the way back in 2015 the mcu
hammers on the idea that its version of
clint barton would much rather be out on
his farm with his wife and kids than
doing superhero stuff being an avenger
is essentially a very dangerous chore
for this man hawkeye triples down on
clint's frustration with his apparent
inability to ever stay in dad mode for
as long as he'd like he frequently
voices his desire to wrap up this ordeal
so he can get back to the barton farm
for christmas indeed the show tells us
family is the most important thing in
the world to hawkeye despite that he
casually destroyed maya lopez's family
at one point and evidently did this
because wilson fisk wanted him to it's
one thing if ekko loses interest in
clint as a target and upon learning that
her father's death was pretty much
kingpin's idea refocuses her wrath
elsewhere it's another thing if the mcu
keeps hand waving away clint's post-snap
pre-blip years as the bloodthirsty
slaughter machine ronin after all frank
castle's tralala attitude about taking
the lives of other human beings
frequently puts him at odds with his
fellow superheroes why does everyone
seem so eager to let hawkeye off the
hook
after the defeat of thanos at the
conclusion of 2019's avengers end game
the mcu has lacked a looming threat with
the final boss energy of josh brolin's
purple space fascist could king pen
become the mcu's new final boss okay
sure echo appears to put a bullet in
them at the end of hawkeye but frankly
unless we see a corpse we've got to
assume wilson fisk still lives and shall
resume menacing denizens of new york
city sooner or later wilson fisk
reemerged into live-action marvel at the
conclusion of episode 5 in the role of
secret evil mastermind alongside the
shocking revelation that eleanor bishop
was involved in his schemes as far as
the kingpin goes there's lots of stuff
hawkeye doesn't tell us how did fisk get
out of prison where he absolutely
appeared to be headed for an indefinite
duration at the conclusion of daredevil
season 3. why does he apparently wear a
hawaiian shirt and a fedora now where's
vanessa does he have a long-term plan to
fix his city by destroying it and
building it back up or is he simply
hoarding as much wealth and power as
possible is bullseye still lurking
somewhere out on the fringes
clint spends a decent amount of hawkeye
chasing down a macguffin in the form of
a rolex watch recovered from avengers
tower it could be used to reveal the
identity of a retired former co-worker
some folks figured this ex-colleague of
hawkeyes might be nick fury which would
make sense as he factors heavily into
the upcoming secret invasion series a
few of us also wondered if the rolex
might connect us to agent phil coulson
seeing as how the mcu has been tossing
its fair share of old toys back in the
sandbox as of late but the most
prescient among us correctly guessed
that the rolex contained the identity
and location of laura barton which
explains why clint was especially
concerned about it falling into the
wrong hands
we've got 90 seconds to find the watch
everything else is second there let's go
but if laura barton used to be a shield
agent what did she do we don't know but
since she appears knowledgeable about
and indifferent towards clint's highly
homicidal activities as ronan we can
safely guess her job got a little
gnarlier than transcribing emails and
fetching coffee when clint takes a
bathroom break from rogers the musical
during episode 1 he notices someone has
scribbled thanos was right in sharpie
marker on a sing in rapid succession
clint is confronted with one side of the
culture that turns the horrors he
experienced during the battle of new
york into sugary pop entertainment while
the other side consists of clueless
edgelords who performatively idolized
the cosmic demon that temporarily killed
clint's family and permanently killed a
few of his teammates it's a poignant
moment that's totally undermined by that
thanos was right coffee mug a few
episodes later let's set the whole
genocidal snap aside for a moment for
the sake of making a point if a bad guy
was directly responsible for a situation
that caused your best friend to fall off
a cliff to her death how comfortable
would you be drinking hot cocoa out of
that bad guy's unofficial fan
merchandise
[Music]
have you ever heard of larping
not pink
that's some sort of leisure activity
why does hawkeye the show think larping
is so funny once grylls the larper lifts
clint's old ronin uniform from the
smoldering ashes of kate's apartment
clint tracks him down at an outdoor
live-action role-playing event afterward
grill's larping organization
inexplicably remains involved in various
goings-on throughout the rest of hawkeye
the show appears to assume we will all
find the notion of adults engaged in
sword and sorcery themed fantasy combat
scenarios insanely quirky and charming
larping related references and humor
felt fresh in 2009 when lifestyle
sections of newspapers published
articles that winkingly declared nerds
are counter-intuitively cool here in the
eerily soothing early phase of obama's
america larping is still a thing of
course but it hasn't been the subject of
frequent media attention for some time
the larping stuff in hawkeye just feels
awkward dated and a little like the show
is poking fun at geeks with unusual
hobbies which is an awfully strange
decision for a marvel show
a better version of hawkeye might have
been 7 8 or maybe even 10 episodes
there's a lot going on and hawkeye
sometimes falters in its effort to keep
way too many plates spinning at once
inevitably some characters feel
underserved and that's especially the
case for jack dukane aka the swordsman
until episode 6. at the beginning of
hawkeye jack seems poised as the series
central big bad by the end of episode 5
he's the fifth tier threat underneath
kingpin echo eleanor bishop and elena
bulova by episode 6 it's clear that he's
not really a villain at all hopefully
there's life after hawkeye for the
swordsman tony dalton's blend of
cavalier swashbuckler and oblivious
comedy relief certainly has potential as
a foil for other second string avengers
on a different series
when disney plus announced a hawkeye
show that would feature clint barton and
kate bishop some fans of matt fraction
and david aha's indispensable 2012
series envisioned a live action version
of this standard setting sequential art
saga we always knew the show couldn't be
a direct adaptation of the comic the
mcu's clint is a stoic family man
whereas the clint of marvel comics at
the time is a cynical damaged bachelor
only some of fractions hawkeye takes
place during christmas as opposed to the
whole story iron man appears in the
comic but tony stark is obviously
unavailable to do anything in the mcu at
this juncture to its credit the disney
plus hawkeye manages to combine street
level combat with espionage and intrigue
that have global implications and
definitely stays true to some aspects of
fractions hawkeye sadly one element that
should have been easy to transfer to
disney plus is one of the show's bigger
letdowns with all due respect to
talented canine actor jolt lucky the
pizza dog has nothing to do on tv's
hawkeye he shows up in the first episode
kate rescues him and then he spins the
rest of the series waiting around for
someone to take him for a walk lucky is
a crucial component in the comics but
the show essentially reduces him to
living iconography seriously disney has
tons of practice with stories about
animals who saved the day how did they
drop the ball on this one
we realized the television program's
relative resemblance to a comic book
from 10 years ago isn't really a
meaningful criterion of quality most
viewers don't care that clint not kate
is supposed to rescue lucky from the
tracksuits or that clint is supposed to
explain the effectiveness of boomerang
arrows to kate not the other way around
but if disney plus wants to make it up
to the many many comics nerds that is
disappointed by deviating from the
source material it never actually
promised it would follow then it should
send kate bishop and lucky to los
angeles for the presently assumed season
2 and follow the events collected in
volume 3 of the hawkeye trade paperbacks
kate gets tired of clint's bs and moves
to la where the events of hawkeye number
16 lead her to help an obvious brian
wilson proxy out of a terminal funk
disney plus adapting this story would
attract and merge their demographics of
mcu die hards and boomer pop obsessives
plus it would be a lot of fun to see
kate and lucky out on the west coast
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]